we're gonna look at transformations
right my transformations we mean if you
scale things if we stretch them out or
if we shift these right we translate
okay those are the two important kinds
of transformations they're going to look
at and reflections as well that kind of
comes as
boy now let's start with a super simple
one okay now I brought this as basically
an import of this but some things have
happened horizontally and vertically I
haven't moved around at all and I
haven't done any reflection I'm just
sort of making it bigger in some
directions okay now which directions am
i making it bigger I want to make it
really clear that this the best way I
think the most on the least error-prone
way in the quickest way to make sure you
get this onto accurate is to borrow from
what we just don't over here so this is
the reason why I point drew your
attention to it right if you've got this
guy right in your back pocket okay it's
your best way to make sure that this
answer is going to be accurate I have to
do one more thing to this to make us be
able to help us able to use that more
hopefully okay that's all I'm good to
semi-humid - okay the - what is it
effect does it affect my horizontal
scale or my vertical scale and
horizontal that's quite obvious because
it's modifying the X right is three well
that's that's the vertical scale isn't
it but that's not entirely obvious the
way that it's been written right now I
think it's more helpful even though it
might seem less intuitive you read to
write it like this
okay I'm gonna encourage you to do this
that three is modifying something
vertical so therefore it really should
be attached to the wine now that I've
got it written in this form all the
things that are luckier with vertical
heat all the things my carry over the
horizontal here I'm gonna launch it to
domain and range now have a look at this
right this is exactly the same as this
except at the moment I've substituted Y
on 3 for Y and I'll substitute 2x 4x did
you see that okay so all I need to do to
work out domain and range a bit of
graphic is to say instead of X I have 2x
do you see that I get to the same
function this 2x I could have called a
theta and I just
you know just say right that's it but
right now I've just called it a
different angle so now all I want to do
is turn this into make X the subject
right well I mean X is in the middle you
get the idea what do I have to do to all
three parts of this to make X that's
object just division right that's not
complicated so that's why I mean we
often think ma this is making it thinner
well this is giving you the analogize to
why we're dividing everything by two
that's why it takes up the space
in exactly the same way I think about
this range restriction and I say well
instead of Y I have Y on three so
instead of minus PI to less than or
equal to Y I'm gonna have Y on three in
the middle and now again to make Y the
subject Gomez I have multiplied through
okay which of course we kind of used to
mean you guys have done this for so long
that when you look at this I think most
of you like oh yeah it stretches out
three times that is what it's doing but
the algebra comes from here like is
actually a division on Y okay let's draw
a very brief image of this it's going to
look exactly like that when this driver
yeah right because there's been no
translation or anything like that it's
still going to be centered on the origin
but all that's going to change is where
our extremities are going to be okay so
shape yeah so if you have a template
chances are you have two possibly three
different sizes for your sine curve if
you use I mean I pretty much always use
the biggest one because it's easiest to
label on there yeah you might have an
extra one hiding in there whichever one
you use so long as they don't I'm who's
fishing is to Liz on Friday which one
now the only place where this is a
problem is if you need more than one
graph to them on the same set of axes
and then you know they don't really
still do need to know this by hand but
otherwise I'll expect if you're using a
template this graph that graph to be
physically the same size but the
difference is one of the differences you
know here and here I'm not going to
they're going to be negative a heart and
my quiet this is going to be instead of
reading part two negative three clown 2
all the way up to you
the answer is yes you need to point for
scale of this and it's right with a fact
I have two points of scale online where
is he up when I draw it essentially as I
would I don't know where it ends and yes
so that's why I have to put behind me
okay good let's have a look at a simple
translation now okay we'll do this guy
simple simple translation now I just
can't move science for the sake of
simplicity of it what should I do to
peace and one step before I can come
ahead and release domain and range stuff
I'm already there what will I do and I
multiply through by two should make
clear that the huh is really affecting
the vertical over there all right so now
I've got this and this is the strength
of using this just remember in this
domain arrange thing not only does it
help you remember this better but you
don't you're you almost enough to think
in this case right again to work out
domain the domain is related 1 and 1 for
whatever this is right instead of X or
2x I have looks take away 1 so that's
what I was thinking is
what will I do to make extra subject
just gonna add instead of any bullish
interview anyone gives me this which by
the way you know we get confused about
which way am i shifting left or right
this doesn't leave any life you don't
have to think obviously I've gone that
way when you draw your 0 & 2
clearly you've gone to the right okay so
there's no confusion about which
direction is this shifting me in so
that's that pot and to work out the
range from negative 2 to bless you and
get here it's straightforward I want you
to do is divide through and you can see
how would you describe the effect it's
going to be sort of squashed down right
it's shorter than it usually is which is
what you're normally thinking oh yeah
it's 1/2 the proper height okay let's do
a brief tour again
you can see by the way the importance of
working out the domain and range because
they tell me already where I need to
draw my actual graph and I don't need to
waste half as a set of axes because I
can see I'm only going to have a
positive part of the domain and then I'm
going to draw accordingly so at negative
0.04 that's yeah yeah
don't forget your vertical it's just
like usual I think